This lecture is Basics
of Sacral Diagnosis.
Basically, by the
end of this lecture,
we should be able to
describe the basics
of sacral landmarks
and their locations.
You'll be able
to describe how
to perform and
interpret motion
tests for the
sacral diagnosis.
You'll be able to
describe the different
sacral axes and
their significances.
You'll be able to
describe physiologic
and non-physiologic
sacral dysfunctions and
what types of sacral
dysfunctions fall
into each category
and how they're named.
You'll also be able
to apply the rules of
L5 on the sacrum to
make a sacral diagnosis
if you're only given
an L5 diagnosis.
So this is the outline.
So first of all, sacral
problems, you know,
they're clinically
significant in all
different aspects of
medicine. Pediatrics, OB,
trauma, psych.
In pediatrics and
in adult medicine,
GI problems, GU
problems, pulmonary
problems can
involve the sacrum.
OB-GYN, there are a
lot of different issues
that can occur that
can involve sacral
diagnoses. trauma and
injuries obviously
can involve the sacrum
and musculoskeletal
pain back pain
headaches leg length
discrepancies uh
different gait problems
walking problems they
all can affect the
sacrum as well and also
there's a sometimes
a fascial drag
involving the sacrum can
can cause someone to
be more depressed so
it has psych issues
as well and these
are just some of the
many different areas.
Just basically remember
that there are five
segments to the sacrum
embryologically with
35 centers of ossification.
The sacrum can
get strained not only
between the joints of
the SI joints and the
L5, but there can be
intraosseous strains
within the sacrum itself.
most of the segments
of the sacrum
fused by between
25 and 35 years
of age. S1 and
S2 might not fuse
until like in
the 30s or later.
So remember
that the sacrum
is suspended
between the ilia.
So you've got the sacrum
suspended
between the ilia.
It's connected to
the ischial bones,
the ischia, the
ischial tuberosities.
It's got those
ligaments there.
It supports the spinal
column, and the pelvis
basically rests on
the lower extremity
via the femurs, the
femoral heads over here.
The lumbosacral
junction is important.
The angle that's
formed with the
sacrum and the
L5 is called the
lumbosacral angle
or Ferguson's angle.
The angle is between
horizontal and
the sacral base, the
way the sacral base
is, and that's what
forms the angle.
So it's not the
sacral base in L5.
It's the sacral base
with the horizon.
Normally, that's
approximately
25 to 35 degrees.
an increase in the
lumbosacral angle
creates a greater
vector force
which increases
lumbosacral strain
so just know that the
bigger the angle the
more strain at the
lumbosacral junction
so it's important to
know that the sacral
base which is the
top of the sacrum
the inferior
lateral angle of the
sacrum which is
this part here
the median crest is a
good landmark to know.
And these are going
to be the sacral,
also the sacral
sulci, which we'll
get into a little
bit more later,
located over here.
They're also going to
be important to know.
Some anatomic
abnormalities, there's
sometimes what's called
the lumbarization
of S1, where if S1 is
not fused to S2, it
becomes almost like
an L6 type of picture.
And this picture
here, it's not fused
over here, but it's
still fused over here.
And you could also get
sacralization of L5,
which means that now
L5 becomes fused to the
sacrum, so it becomes
part of the sacrum.
And in this picture,
you've got unilateral
sacralization, but it's
still sacralization
because it's attached
to the sacrum.
The sacroiliac joint
has kind of this
L-shaped joint,
L-shaped surface
that articulates
with the inominates.
And the shape of the
joint is different
depending on what
level you're at. So
superiorly, the
sacrum is more concave
and the inominates
more convex.
More towards the middle
of the lumbosacral
junction, there's kind
of a mixture here, the
zigzag type of motion,
of shape. And then
at the inferior portion,
now the sacrum becomes
more convex with respect
to the innominate.
So those are just
things to think about.
The sacrum also
is involved with
the nervous
system. You've got
the ventral
roots coming off.
you have the
parasympathetic um
parasympathetics of
s2 and s4 all come out
come out in here as
well s2 to s4 and then
you've got the
sympathetic chain
ganglion which continues
all the way down
and eventually stops
down here at the
ganglion impar which is
that which is a roughly
anterior to the sacral
coccidial junction.
So if the sacrum
is not in the right
position, it could be
putting strain on these
nerves, any ventral nerve
roots, parasympathetics,
or the sympathetic
chain ganglia.
Something to keep in
mind is that the dora
attaches, this is the
dora surrounding the
spinal cord, and the
dura comes down and
attaches at S2 and at
the coccyx, coccyx 1. So
there's a dural connection
all the way from
the sacrum up to the
skull. So if you fall
on your backside and
do something to the
anatomical structure
relationship of the sacrum,
that can cause a
dural strain all the
way up into the head. So
you wonder why somebody
who fell on their
backside is having
headaches. That could
be part of the problem.
Another thing to
remember is the
piriformis muscle, just
because it's a major
player, it attaches
from the femur
to the anterior
portion of the sacrum.
And that's involved
with external rotation
of the hip, extension
of the thigh and
abduction of the thigh
if the hip is flexed.
So that's just something
to remember when
you're treating the
sacrum. You might want
to take a look at the
piriformis because
that might need to
be treated before you
can get that sacrum to
move properly again.
So now we have
these landmarks,
the important
landmarks for making
a sacral diagnosis.
We've got the
sacral base, which
is right here.
You've got L5, which
is right there.
And of course, you've
got the lumbosacral
junction, which I
don't have labeled
here, but that's
important to know.
You have the PSIS.
We have the inferior
lateral angle of the
sacrum, the ILA, this
moon shape down here.
this moon-shaped
marking that I put down
here, and then we have
the sacral sulcus,
which is right here.
Sacral sulcus is
medial and slightly
superior, just medial,
and slightly
superior to the PSIS,
and you're going to
be comparing landmarks
when you're making
a sacral diagnosis.
So the motion at the
lumbar sacral junction,
you're going to be
testing that with a
sphinx test and
with a spring test.
You're going
to be checking
the motion of
the SI joint
at the SI joint with
cephalide motion
of the ILAs.
You're also going to
be checking motion at
the sacroiliac joint
doing the ASIS compression
test, as well as the
C deflection test.
and you will also need to
make an L5 diagnosis for
when you make a
sacral diagnosis
because that's
important as well.
Now there are a bunch
of axes for the sacrum.
There's seven here.
The ones that
we talk about
most frequently
are the numbers
two through six.
So you have a
Number two is a
right oblique axis.
So the oblique
axis is named from
the superior to
inferior aspect.
So the right oblique
axis starts at the
right aspect of the
sacral base and goes
down to, down through
the left lower
portion of the SI
joint. So it goes from
superior on the right
to inferior on the
left. That's a right
oblique axis. The
left oblique axis
starts out on the left
superiorly and goes
down to the right.
Then you have three
transverse axes. You have
the superior transverse
axis, the middle
transverse axis, and
the inferior transverse
axis. The superior
transverse axis is more
for respiratory and
cranial sacral motion.
The middle transverse
axis is more for postural
motion, and the
inferior transverse axis
is more with gait and
enominate rotation.
Okay, let's go. Next
one. So like I said,
superior transverse
axis is the respiratory
and cranial sacral
motion around the axis.
In inhalation, when you
breathe in or during
the flexion phase or
the inhalation phase
of cranial sacral mechanism,
primary respiratory
mechanism, which
we'll get into next
year, the sacral base
during inhalation moves
posteriorly and a
little superiorly. The
thoracic and pelvic
diaphragms flatten and
the diameters become,
they increase, and
the spinal curves
flatten. In exhalation,
the sacral base moves
anteriorly and a
little inferiorly.
Thoracic and pelvic
diaphragms dome, and
the diameters decrease,
and the spinal curves
become exaggerated.
With the middle
transverse axis, this
is postural motion,
seated or standing.
The sacral base moves
anterior and that's
called nutation
or moves posterior
and that's called
counter-nutation. When
you're forward
bending and backward
bending, you get motion
around this axis.
So this video here
isn't playing.
So let's do this.
So we'll play this video
so you could see it.
That's anterior,
that's nutation and
counter-nutation, or
posterior nutation,
so you can see it bigger.
And then you have the
inferior transverse
axis, which is
involved with gait.
Now if you look at
these, on the left,
watch what happens
as the left leg moves
forward, The anominate
goes back, and
the sacrum moves,
rotates left over an
oblique axis. So as
the, watch it again.
So the sacrum is
going to, the sacrum
rotates left over a left
oblique axis. so the
axis is going this way
and as the leg left
leg moves forward
the sacrum actually
rotates to the left
over an oblique axis and
in this one the
the one on the
right it shows the
same idea except
now the it explodes
it a little bit so
you can see the
sacrum a little more
clearly and it's
the right leg that's
moving forward so the
sacrum is going to
rotate right over a
right oblique axis.
That's a slow motion.
Don't do it again. As
the right leg moves
forward, the sacrum
rotates right over a right
oblique axis, so the
right oblique axis.
So the right oblique
axis starts at the upper
right and goes across
to the lower left.
That's rotating
forward over that axis.
Get my pen back here.
So now when you have
a transverse axis, you
have bilateral movement
around a transverse
axis. Bilateral
meaning what? You've
got both sides of the
sacral base are moving
anterior or posterior
around this axis.
So this diagram on the
left is showing how
the sacrum moves anterior,
sacral base moves
anterior forward over
the transverse axis,
and that means if
the sacral base is
moving forward, that
means that the apex of
the sacrum is going
to be moving backward.
On the other side,
if the sacral base
is bilaterally
extending, so now the
base is coming back
towards you, that
means that the apex
is moving anterior.
So again,
sacral base is
bilaterally flexing over
transverse axis, or it's
bilaterally extending
over transverse axis.
That's what happens.
Now, if it's unilaterally
moving around a
transverse axis, notice
the transverse axis
is in quotes here,
because unilateral
motion is really not
moving over any axis.
But for diagrammatic
purposes, we have to
talk about it. So
when you have a sacral
moving unilaterally
over a transverse axis,
that means that one
side, in this case,
the top case, the left
side is moving, the
left sacral base is
moving anterior, and
the right sacral base
is moving posterior.
So diagrammatically,
when the left
sacral base moves
anterior, if
you were behind
feeling symmetry at
the sacral sulci,
which are here,
sacral sulcus,
you're checking
symmetry. If it's
unilaterally flexing
on the left, that means
the left side is
moving forward, left
sacral base moving
forward, so this is
going to be deeper
over here on the left.
And likewise,
the left inferior
lateral angle is going
to be more posterior
on this side because
it's coming back.
It's coming posterior.
So with a unilateral
sacral flexion, you've
got, in this case,
a left unilateral
sacral flexion. You
have the sacral base
deeper on the, the
sacral sulcus deeper on
the left. The base is
moving forward and the
ILA is coming back
posteriorly. So it's
feel it when you're
palpating. And the
bottom one here shows
a right unilateral
sacral flexion. So
the right sacral base
is moving forward.
The right inferior
lateral angle is
coming backward towards
us. So when you check
symmetry, the right
sacral sulcus is
going to be deeper,
farther away from us
than the left sacral
sulcus. And the right
posterior ILA is
going to be more
posterior and inferior.
The sacrum can also
move around oblique
axes. So we talked
about how a left oblique
axis starts out in the
left upper and then
ends in the left, the
right lower. And a
right oblique axis
starts out in the right
upper and ends down
here, the left lower.
So here's your sacrum
and there's a nice
big red axis going
through this is a left
axis on top right
oblique axis on the
bottom so for we're
just going to talk about
the left right now so
i'm going to talk about
examples of a left
rotation around the
left oblique axis and
a left rotation around
the right oblique
axis so if you imagine
this sacrum the big
picture on the left, if
the sacrum started to
turn towards the left,
the anterior portion
of the sacrum
would be looking
towards the left,
okay? So whatever
happens here
around these
axes, the anterior
portion of the sacrum
should be turning
and looking
towards the left.
So if we have
a left rotation
around the left
oblique axis,
we have here's
your left oblique
axis so the
the sacral base
on the right
is going to be
rotating around the
around this left axis
so that the sacral
base on the right is
going to be more anterior
or deeper when we
palpate, and the
left ILA is going
to be more posterior
when we palpate.
So if it's rotating
left over a left oblique
axis, the right
sacral base is more
anterior and the left
ILA is more posterior.
Now we go down to the
left rotation around
a right oblique
axis, if you
look at the final
product here, it's
still the same way.
The sacral base appears
anterior on the right,
so it's deeper on the
right, and the ILA
appears more posterior
and inferior on the
left. So the positioning
of the two are the
same because it's
looking towards the left.
The difference is now,
instead of the right
sacral base moving
anteriorly, it's actually
the left sacral base
is coming posteriorly
and the right ILA
is going anteriorly.
But the final product,
palpation-wise,
as far as sulci and
ILA's go, is that
it appears as a
deep sulcus on the
right and a posterior
ILA on the left.
So the next picture
here kind of
demonstrates it a
little bit more,
where we have on the
left-hand side, we
have a left-on-left
forward sacral torsion.
So left-on-left, you
have the left axis,
and the right sacral
base is going to go
anterior, and the left
ILA is going to come
posterior. So it looks
kind of like this.
It looks like This sacral
base is a little deeper.
This ILA is more
posterior in the diagram,
which this is, you
should probably get
used to this diagram,
this home plate
looking diagram here,
because you'll be using
it when you're making
your diagnosis.
But right here,
you've got the deep
sulcus on the right,
the posterior ILA
on the left. So this
is a left-on-left
forward sacral
torsion or rotation.
On the right-hand
side, we've got
neutral on top, but
now we've got the
sacral base is coming
back towards us,
and the ILA is
moving away from us.
But still, you've
got a deep sulcus on
the right and the
posterior ILA on the
left. And on this
side, for the left
on left, you have
deep sulcus on the
right and the posterior
ILA on the left.
So the positioning
is similar, but in
one, you're rotating
left on a left axis.
And then the
other one, you're
rotating left
on a right axis.
But in both cases,
the sacrum, the front
of the sacrum is
looking to the left.
So now,
in order to make a
sacral diagnosis,
you need the prone
static landmarks.
You're going to do
a sphinx or a spring
test, which we'll
talk about, and you're
going to do the
seated flexion test.
The static landmarks
you're going to be using
are L5, which technically
you'll probably
make a diagnosis of
L5, so I'll be using
motion testing as well
for L5, but you need
to diagnose L5. You're
going to look at the
sacral sulcus and see
which side is deeper.
You're going to
look and see,
look at the ILA
and see which one
is more posterior
and inferior.
These are
static findings.
So the diagnosis of L5
is important because
if L5 is rotated
in opposite of the
sacrum, so if the
sacrum, if you decide
with your landmarks
and throughout the
diagnosis that you
think the sacrum is
rotated left and L5 is
rotated to the right,
then that's a torsion.
If L5 is rotated
left and the sacrum
is rotated left, then
that's going to be
a sacral rotation.
So think of a torsion
where if you have
a towel and you're
twisting two ends of
the towel, the two
ends are going in
opposite directions,
it's a torsion. If you
have a towel and
you're twisting both
ends the same direction,
you're just rotating
the towel around,
so you're not really
doing anything. So
that's a rotation.
How do you check the
symmetry of
the cell side?
Well, you find the
PSIS. You go a little
medial, a little
superior. You put
your thumbs in the
sacral cell side,
and you compare which
one feels deeper.
And if one feels
deeper, the other feels
shallower. So keep that
in mind, too, when you're
taking exams. Someone
might say you have
a shallow sulcus on one
side, and that means
that the deep sulcus
is on the other side.
if you're checking
the symmetry of the
ilas your thumbs go
to the inferior aspect
of the ilas and you're
checking for um to
see if which one's a
little more inferior
and then if you just
move your thumbs to
the posterior aspect
of the ila you could
check the symmetry
to see which one is
more posterior because
the ila that's more
posterior and inferior
is the one that
we're typically talking
about. But again,
tests might say the
ILA is anterior and
superior on one side,
so you have to know
the other side is
posterior and inferior.
So what are some of
the special tests on
the sacrum? Well, we
have the lumbosacral
spring test, which is
a good test to check
to see if the sacrum
is moving forward
or backward. So if
you do a spring test,
basically you find the
lumbosacral junction
and you gently compress
anteriorly over
the lumbosacral
junction, just like Dr.
DiGiovanna is doing
here in this picture.
If it springs,
if there's give,
then it is a
negative spring test.
If it doesn't give,
then it's a positive
spring test. And
some people say the
absence of springability
is like a steel
-like resistance
or something. But if
it doesn't spring,
it's a...
It's a positive
test, and that also
means that it's
non-physiologic
because you want
to have spring.
Let's see if we can
get this to work.
Because look at the
lumbosacral junction.
That's normal motion
at the lumbosacral
junction. So if you
spring over this
lumbosacral junction,
you should get a little
bit of motion going
anterior. If you
can't get the motion
going anterior like
this, if it doesn't
move like that, if it
just stays, then that's
a positive spring
test, and that's non
-physiologic. If it
moves, if it springs,
it's physiologic.
Next test, which
is similar to a
spring test, is the
sphinx test, or also
called the backward
bending test.
Basically, for the
sphinx test, what you're
going to do is you're
going to put one finger
on each sacral
sulcus, and your index
fingers are in the sacral
sulci, and your thumbs
are on the inferior
lateral angles,
bilaterally. The patient's
going to go up onto
her elbows, and as she
goes up onto her elbows,
if the findings
become more symmetric,
then that's a negative
sphinx test. That's
good. If the findings
become more asymmetric,
that's bad. That's a
positive sphinx test.
Positive sphinx test
is equivalent to a
positive spring test.
They're non-physiologic.
So there's a problem
there. If the
spring test or the
sphinx test are negative,
then it's a physiologic
motion of the
sacrum, so it's
probably going to be a
physiologic dysfunction,
with one exception.
and we'll talk
about that so then
you have the
seated flexion test
where you come with
your thumbs inferior
to the psis's patients
seated on the floor
have the patient bend
forward slowly and you
watch to see which
psis moves first and
furthest side that
moves first and furthest
is the positive side
of this of the seated
flexion test And the
positive C deflection
test typically
indicates if there's a
sacral torsion, so the
sacrum's rotating around
an oblique axis, or
sacral rotation where
the sacrum's rotating
around an oblique
axis, this positive C
deflection test will
indicate the side
opposite the positive C
deflection test will
be the side of the
oblique axis. So if
you have a positive C
deflection test on the
right, that would indicate
a left oblique axis
if the dysfunction
is a sacral torsion
or a sacral rotation.
Cytopause test is
typically used in naming
of unilateral sacral
category of dysfunction.
So, in other words,
if you have a positive
seated flexion test
on the right, and
all your other findings
are pointing to a
unilateral sacral flexion,
then it's going to
be a right unilateral
sacral flexion. If
you have a positive
seated flexion test on
the right, and all of
your other findings
point to a right unilateral
sacral extension,
then you have a right
unilateral
sacral extension.
And, like I said, the
side opposite of the
positive test is used
for naming the axis
for sacral torsions
and sacral rotations.
But the patients don't
always follow the
rules. So if
you're checking the
landmarks and doing the
motion testing, like
the spring test and
the sphinx test,
and you decide that
your patient has a,
all those things
point to one type of
dysfunction, either
right on right forward
sacral torsion or
a right unilateral
sacral flexion,
whatever it is. and your
C deflection test
finding does not go
along with all of
your other findings,
go with all of your other
findings. So it's
very important.
So this thing, oops.
So this thing here,
this is supposed
to be a star.
This means that if
in real life, If your
spring test, your sphinx
test, your sacral,
your deep sulci symmetry,
and your inferior
ILA symmetry findings
are all pointing to one
type of dysfunction,
and your C-deflection
test is pointing to
a different type of
dysfunction, go with
all your other findings.
Or also, you
can double-check
your C-deflection
test, too.
But the patients don't
read the book. So
the bodies don't always
follow the rules.
So just keep
that in mind when
you're making
your diagnoses.
Remember, a negative
C-deflection test will
mean either there's
no somatic dysfunction
or there's a bilateral
somatic dysfunction,
like a bilateral
flexion or bilateral
extension. Because
if both sides are
flexed or extended,
it's going to give
you a false negative
C-deflection test.
ASAS compression test
is nonspecific, you're
going to compress
on the ASAS down
towards the SI joint,
one side, then the other
side, compare motion,
the side with less
motion is the
positive side, that's
nonspecific, it indicates
that there's some kind
of problem at the
sacroiliac joint, we
don't know if it's
sacrum on ilium or ilium
on sacrum, but it's
there as a screening.
Another screening test
you can use is the
ILA motion test, where
with the patient prone,
you put your thenar
eminences on the ILAs,
and you compress one
side up towards the
sacroiliac joint, then
you compress the other
side up towards the
sacroiliac joint, and
you compare sides and
see if one side is
more restricted than the
other. If it is, that
tells you that there's
a problem over there
on probably on that
side, but it doesn't
really give you much
much else to go on
although clinically you if
you notice the asymmetry
and then you do a
treatment and go back
and check the symmetry
and it's better than
you know you've you've
treated the sacrum
um and there are
there are treatments
you could you'll you
might learn later on
where you don't
necessarily make a sacral
diagnosis but you
know this the ila
is restricted and
you go and you you do
a treatment and then
go back and check
the the motions again
and it gets better
but for our purposes
we're going to
be making full
diagnoses of the sacrum
all right so you
heard me talking about
physiologic versus
non-physiologic
categories of sacral
dysfunctions physiologic
dysfunctions produce
a restriction within
the normal range of
motion of a joint
examples of these are
the forward sacral
torsion so if the sacrum
is rotating forward
over an oblique axis
or forward sacral
rotation same thing
going forward over an
oblique axis, or bilateral
sacral flexions, non
-physiologic dysfunctions,
the joints in
a position that's
not obtained by usual
physiologic motion. So
usually this is traumatic,
but may occur in
a patient with
hypermobility. So
backward sacral
torsions, backward
sacral rotations, the
sacrum is rotating
backwards over an
oblique axis. Unilateral
sacral shears, So
unilateral sacral
flexions and unilateral
sacral extensions are
non-physiologic. The
thing I mentioned
earlier about the spring
test, a unilateral
sacral flexion will
have a negative spring
test because the sacrum
is moving forward.
So it's going to be a
negative spring test,
negative sphinx
test. So that was the
one that I said doesn't
quite fit the rules.
So a negative spring,
negative sphinx
test is going to give
you, will indicate
forward torsions,
rotations, or bilateral
flexions, and it
would also indicate a
sacral flexion,
unilateral sacral flexion.
Then positive spring
test, positive
sphinx is going
to be backwards
torsions, backwards
sacral rotations,
unilateral extensions,
unilateral
extensions, and
bilateral sacral
extensions. All
right. So with
the physical exam,
you do your seat
deflection test.
Is it right or
left or neither?
Do the Sphinx test, is
it positive or negative?
Check out five diagnosis.
Is it type one?
Is it a type two?
What's the side bending?
What's the rotation?
And the side bending
and rotation are
going to be in type one
or type two is going
to be important with
the next thing we're
going to talk about.
Then you got the deep
sacral sulci. Is it
deep on the right? Is it
deep on the left? Is
it deep on both sides?
Is it deep on neither
side? Are they both
posterior? They're both
shallow. It depends.
And then last thing
you're going to
check for the ILAs.
You're going to see
for posterior inferior
ILAs on the right,
on the left, both
sides, neither side.
You're going to
write all this down
and you're going to
learn how to draw
this out and figure
it out in the lab.
So the main category
is sacral dysfunctions,
bilateral dysfunctions.
It could be
bilateral flexions,
bilateral extensions.
Unilateral dysfunction
is also called
sacral shears,
unilateral sacral
flexion, unilateral
sacral extension.
You have sacral
torsions. You could have
right on right, forward
sacral torsion, right
on left, backward
sacral torsion, left on
left, forward sacral
torsions, left on right,
backward sacral
torsions. You could also
have sacral rotations.
Sacral rotation, similar
to torsion, except
L5 is going to be
rotating in the same
direction as the sacrum.
And that's pretty
much what I just said.
So you need to know,
you need to know
what's physiologic,
what's non-physiologic.
So these are, these
are all important.
And remember, when
you're naming a
sacral torsion,
sacral torsions are
named for the
rotation on the axis.
So you figure out
how the sacrum is
rotating and on what
axis is it. So if it's
rotating left on a
left oblique axis,
your diagnosis is a
left-on-left sacrum.
And then the torsion
or rotation gets
put in depending on
what L5 is doing.
If it's rotating left
on a right oblique
axis, then it's a left
rotation on a right
oblique axis. So
it's a left-on-right.
and vice versa.
All right. So I think
I mentioned this
already. Sacral rotations
and torsions have
an oblique axis.
Unilateral sacral
dysfunctions have no
axis. I spent some time
talking about that.
It looks like it's
going over a transverse
axis, but unilateral
sacral dysfunctions
have no real axis.
Bilateral sacral
dysfunctions have a
transverse, middle
transverse axis.
All right, so now
you need to know
the sacral rotations
and torsions
have deep sulcus
and posterior
inferior ILAs on
opposite sides.
The unilateral
sacral dysfunctions
have a deep sulcus and
posterior ILA on
the same side.
And the bilateral
sacral dysfunctions are
either flexed or
extended. So both sides
are coming either
flexing or extending.
Last thing to talk
about is diagnosing
sacral torsions
based on L5.
You need to memorize
this. There's
no other way to
say it, really.
This is laid out in
the handout that's
accompanying this lecture.
It's posted as well.
The review sheet, it
talks about making sacral
diagnosis with the
static landmarks and
the spring tests and
stuff. And then it also
talks about making a
sacral diagnosis based
on L5. So this is just
when, if you're just
given L5 and the question
says L5 is whatever
the diagnosis, what's
the sacrum doing?
That's where you
use these rules.
Otherwise, if you get
a question where it's
talking about L5, but
then it also has the
deep sulcus and the
deep sacral sulcus and
the posterior ILA and
the seed inflection test
and spring test, sphinx
test, then you're
going to be making the
diagnosis the other
way, which you're going
to be doing in lab.
But making it
based on L5,
you need to
memorize these.
L5 will be
rotated opposite
the direction
of the sacrum.
If not, L5 must
be treated first.
So if L5 is
rotated right, then
sacrum is probably
rotated left.
C deflection test
is positive opposite
the axis of rotation.
So based on this,
if you have a L5
rotated right, then –
sorry, we didn't get
to that part yet.
The C-deflex test
is opposite the
axis of rotation.
That's true.
L5 will be side
bending to the
same side as the
oblique axis.
So if you have
L5 side bent
left, then that
means that the
axis is going to
be on the left.
So if I gave you a
question saying L5 is
side bent to the left,
where do you expect
to see the positive
C deflection test?
You would have to
know it's opposite
the axis of
rotation. So L5 is
side bending left.
That means the
axis of rotation
is on the left.
So that means that
the C-deflection
test would be
positive on the right.
So forward torsions
are associated with
neutral lumbar
mechanics of L5, like L5
neutral side bent left
rotated right with a
left-on-left forward
sacral torsion, and L5
neutral side bent
right rotated left with
a right-on-right
forward sacral torsion.
Backward torsions are
associated with non
-neutral lumbar mechanics.
So L5-ERS-right or
L5-FRS-right is going
to be associated with
a left-on-right
backward sacral torsion.
L5-ERS-left or FRS
-left is associated with
a right-on-left
backward sacral torsion.
No sacral rotations
using this model since
the sacrum is rotating
opposite of L5.
So what does this mean?
If you're given L5
ERS right, this means
that L5 has a non-neutral
type 2 dysfunction.
So the axis on
the right, why?
Because it's side
-bend to the right,
side of the side bending.
The positive C
deflection test is on
the left, why?
Because it's opposite
the axis. If the
axis is on the right,
C deflection test is
on the left. Positive
C deflection test
is on the left.
We know the sacrum
is rotating left
because it rotates
opposite L5,
and L5 is rotating
to the right.
So that means the sacrum
is rotating to the left.
So diagnosis is a
left rotation on
a right sacrum.
So left on right,
it's a rotation left
on a right axis. So
a left on right
backward sacral torsion.
Why is it backward?
Well, if the
rotation and the
axis are opposite,
it, it's a
backward torsion.
And then the
same is going
to be for L5 FRS right.
If we have L1
to L5 neutral
rotated right,
sorry, L1 to L5
neutral side bend
left rotated right,
this means that
L5 has a neutral
type 1 dysfunction.
Therefore, the axis
is on the left,
which is the side
of the side bending.
The positive C
deflection test is on the
right because it's
opposite the axis,
which we said the axis
was on the side of
the side bending. The
sacrum is rotating
left because it rotates
opposite the L5.
So the diagnosis is a
left-on-left sacrum,
which is left rotation
on a left axis.
And we know it's
a left-on-left
forward sacral
torsion because if
the rotation axis
are in the same
direction, it's a
forward torsion.
All right, so you
probably want to go over
this a few times
and memorize it, try
to wrap your head
around it a little bit.
And then when you
go into the lab and
check out the lab
lecture and start to
do things in lab,
hopefully all of this
stuff will start
to make more sense.
And that's it. Thank you.